Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, je n'ai pas de question
parce que c'est une semaine particulièrement agréable
pour moi. C'est la semaine du 21 juin,
la semaine du solstice, mais aussi
la semaine des cultures autochtones
au Québec et au Canada.
Donc, je voulais en profiter un peu
pour vous dire comment, depuis quelques années,
j'ai vu une transformation du narratif,
je dirais, de cette semaine-ci.
Avant on était beaucoup obligés
de convaincre les gens de s'intéresser à la culture
des Premières Nations et maintenant,
de plus en plus, la culture générale s'y intéresse.
On voit que cette année,
en 2019, c'est l'Année
internationale des langues autochtones. Juste dernièrement « Innu Nikamu, chanter la résistance »,
a gagné l'Iris du meilleur
documentaire québécois.
Pas le meilleur documentaire autochtone,
le meilleur documentaire québécois.
De plus en plus, la culture
des Premières Nations commence
à « réinfuser » justement la culture générale.
Je trouve que c'est quelque chose
qui est extrêmement positif et que je veux
continuer à encourager, parce que
c'est triste à dire, mais il y a un grand pan
de l'histoire et de la culture des Premières Nations
qui n'est pas apparent au quotidien.
Mais de plus en plus de gens,
et pas juste des Premières Nations,
mais des alliés aussi, qui travaillent très fort
à faire revenir cette culture-là
de l'avant et à la valoriser. Donc n'hésitez pas
à regarder autour de vous quel
événement va se produire,
N'hésitez pas même à vous intéresser
à des auteurs, à des musiciens
des Premières Nations.
Il y a énormément d'activités
qui se passent en ce moment
et puis, quand on parle d'Innu Nikamu,
justement, peut-être
que vous allez avoir envie de faire
le voyage jusqu'à Maliotenam pour visiter
et profiter de ce festival de musique
qui est un des plus grands en Amérique
du Nord pour ce qui est de la musique autochtone.
Mais je peux vous dire que
pour moi, c'est une année pour célébrer,
parce que je vois vraiment une
transformation depuis avant Idle No More,
depuis la crise d'Oka en 1990.
Donc on continue. c'est vraiment
par l'échange entre citoyens qu'on va voir
cette réconciliation apparaître.
Je vous souhaite une belle semaine
et je vous souhaite un très beau 21 juin!